I'm going to introduce a basic
subtraction bar model we would read the
question first all the way through to
get an idea of where we're going then we
would restate the question in terms of a
sentence and answer sentence and I
should have drawn a line here just to
give me some demarcation that I'm gonna
have my arithmetic over here and my bar
model over here so let's read it all the
way through there are 12 teachers at the
park 11 of them went to get coffee how
many adults were still supervising the
children so we would restate the
question in terms of a sense there are
blank adults supervising okay and then
we would start back through and stop
where we can draw something there are 12
teachers okay so we have teachers and we
know how many there are there are 12 of
them to have a quantity of teachers 12
at the park 11 of them went to get
coffee so we know that most of them want
to get coffee you could say that that is
11 of them how many adults were still
supervising the children so how many
were supervising we could say s for
supervising and we would put our
question mark again our question mark
only goes where the final answer would
be so you want your question mark to
line with where your final answer is
okay so we would go over here for the
arithmetic 12 minus 11 is equal to and
you can do a number of things again
let's practice a number bond 12 is 1 and
11 so then I could take away my 11s and
I'm left with 1 so there are 1 adults
supervising then we can get into the
grammar of it but we're not gonna do
that
thank you